ahmed al-masri has come from gaza to
qatar looking for investment he's
invented a robotic glove that's designed
to help palestinian people whose hands
are paralyzed through injuries sustained
during conflicts with israel
i hope we can
come out with this as a prototype i hope
if there is any company or any agent can
support this project then we can make uh
multiples of this robotic handy glove
and provide it to the basiante in
palestine especially in gaza and we have
a lot of patients with paralyzed and
ambition hands after the ugly wall have
been there
competitors from more than 40 countries
are taking part in the first ever
challenge and innovation forum in qatar
judges will evaluate the best ideas over
the next two days and award cash prizes
for those placed first second and third
there's up to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars of prize money to be
won
once the winners from here have been
chosen the participants will be divided
into teams they'll then compete to
design build and test an idea from
scratch over a 48-hour period
one of the organizers is an inventor
himself he knows first hand how
difficult it is to get investment for
new innovations
normally for as an inventor it's very
hard
to start up your company
so what we are doing here
we bring the
inventors
and we call a lot of research and start
up companies
to meet them
and
we hope it will be start of a new
business for them it's hoped this will
become an annual event the winners will
be announced in a week's time
victoria gatenbee al jazeera doha